good morning
and welcome to the final day of the
spectators alternative conference and
indeed the final
panel of the day but uh we've really
saved the best for last i think because
the topic that would have dominated the
news agenda had it not been
for coven 19 this year is the one that
we'll be discussing and that is
can the uk afford its leveling up agenda
if anything more topical now perhaps
given the crisis
and and the importance of getting the
economy back on track today's
uh panel is very kindly hosted by
siemens and i have a fantastic group of
panelists lined up to discuss the topic
but
let's set the scene a bit as part of the
government strategy to recover
from the devastating impact of coven 19
it is moving forward with parts of its
leveling up agenda
spending for infrastructure projects and
green renovations and homes
but it has come under some criticism
notably a lot of the money that they've
pledged isn't new
the new deal that the prime minister
boris johnson put forward back in june
including 5.5 billion pounds worth of
money for transport and infrastructure
turned out to be part of an old budget
the chancellor has come under a similar
criticism when his summer statement was
found to have repackaged 10 billion
pounds
of previously committed spending uh
towards
what seemed like they might be new
initiatives so does britain really have
the money and resources to pursue
a comprehensive leveling up agenda
especially
as it's just spent so much money and
continues to do so
hundreds of billion pounds racking up
the uk's deficit this year
on the covid crisis is it going to need
more support and investment from private
companies and the private sector in
order to
deliver on its promises and as well if
it's going to pursue its net zero agenda
will politicians be able to hit their
targets
without support from the business
community especially as we aim to move
away from fossil fuel dependency
and decarbonize transport network works
so today we're going to discuss in what
ways private financing can help level up
britain's economy more quickly
and stimulate growth get more jobs back
and hopefully
give the country the boost that it needs
over the next few years
i'm delighted to be joined by daniel
cochlin head of external affairs
for the northern powerhouse partnership
robert coville director of the center
for policy studies
joe gideon member of parliament for
stoke on trent central
and will wilson chief executive officer
of siemens mobility
limited and again many thanks to siemens
for sponsoring this panel
so daniel uh let's get two to three
minutes worth of remarks for you we'll
keep them short and snappy
we'll go around the panel so i can abuse
my position as chair ask you a few
questions and then of course
get questions from our audience and just
to remind you that you can submit your
questions
through spectator tv they'll be funneled
straight to me and i'll put your
questions to our panel
daniel to you thanks very much kate and
uh
and good morning everyone um in many
ways i
i just like to take issue with the
central question raised really for this
session
to me it should be how can the uk not
afford its leveling up uh
agenda since the uh since the phrase
leveling up entered
the political lexicon sometime towards
the end of last year
it's been taken to mean relatively
short-term cash injections and
new structures presumably to ensure that
the seats which the conservatives won in
the 2019 general election that
dismantled the the red wall such as such
as joe's
um will be held on to next time around
but
leveling up and and the northern
powerhouse ambition which which preceded
it
cannot be achieved in the short term the
division of an economically balanced
country
is is by its very nature a long-term
project
whether it's tackling historic
north-south divide in educational
attainment which has been
accentuated by the pandemic increasing
productivity by creating skilled jobs in
new sustainable industries or improving
our substandard rail network these are
not challenges that will be addressed in
in one or two
five-year government tenures from our
point of view the historic majority won
uh last year in the election was a
mandate a mandate for long-term reform
one of boris johnson's first major
decisions was to give the green light to
hs2 in full coming all the way to leeds
and manchester
alongside the east west connectivity of
northern powerhouse rail and
whatever the chanterings of those in the
home counties and indeed the views of
the
spectator editor himself uh the impact
hs2 and npr will make on
northern economies will be huge and will
allow these parts of the country that
traditionally and historically not
pulled their way to economic
terms to play a far bigger role in the
uk economic recovery
covert has changed everything no one
would doubt that but in the lifespan of
a once
in a generation opportunity to create a
fairer more balanced
country or or the time frame of a
massive infrastructure project like hs2
kobe will hopefully be a blip a tragic
destructive life-changing blip but a
blip nonetheless
leveling up should be front and center
uh of the economic
recovery not one of the many casualties
of the pandemic
thanks so much daniel robert um uh
daniel's uh stolen a couple of my lines
there um
so leveling up um is um it's important
to remember leveling up is not
just about infrastructure i mean it
everyone sort of thinks about it
as infrastructure in fact when uh when
government sort of looked at this
this issue pretty much every department
realized that it had a you know there
was a bit of leveling up that it could
and
should be doing and um if you talk to
the treasury you know
i think their their view is that
actually skills are as much for part of
it as
infrastructure um but i think you know
i think that the sort of premise of the
question is it it's slightly wrong
leveling up's not just about about cash
there is there is so
we published a very very good cps report
called the rising tide
which uh before the last election which
sort of prefigured a lot of this
agenda and it said you know that it
showed how london and the southeast have
been advantaged
very very much in terms of where public
investment goes to and obviously there
is a need to
to rebalance that um on that you know
the more unbalanced
growth you know countries are the harder
it is for them to grow you know
the connectivity across our major
metropolitan cities outside of london
and
um between them and their sort of their
the
and their sort of satellite communities
is is really workful by
global and european standards but but
we've got to remember you know
the blair government for example poured
billions and billions of pounds into
regional development and it didn't
really it didn't really get
get anywhere you know we we still we
still have these
you know we're still there kind of 10 20
years later complaining about the same
things or
or even more so so i think when we talk
about by leveling up it needs to be a
bit more about money it needs to be
about
attitude it needs and it needs to
involve you know
things like you know devolving genuine
political power it's a responsibility
giving local communities
you know the more of a more control of
what happens in their
in their areas giving them more of a
chance to compete um another cps report
which was written by a guy called rishi
sunak
on freeports was was all about this
we're saying look you know
if we we can use these things we and you
know later we've expanded we talk about
opportunity zones
as well i mean you know there are some
of the most deprived parts of the
country and
um you know in coastal ports and coastal
communities you know
you you need to give them the tools the
tools to
to give give themselves give them a
reason for people to stay there give
them a reason people have good jobs
there give them a reason for industries
to locate there so i think you know um
we do
leveling up is the right agenda but we
can't just think about it in terms of
our finances that said in terms of the
finances on the infrastructure side at
least we do have the money um
you know the um we can borrow at
historically low rates
um you know the uh the the
the in fact you know historically a very
good response to a recession is
to uh start pouring concrete so um you
know we've said
please we've always told the government
please don't you know
your your limits for infrastructure
spending are meant to be a percentage of
gdp
please to stick to the old percentage of
gdp rather than
crunching down infrastructure spending
because the economy has crunched down
that would be
counterproductive but also please try
and front load as much of that as
possible and you know stop
you know rather than sort of um you know
doing sort of grand project which won't
actually result in anything for the next
five years
let's start building roundabouts
building you know filling in potholes
doing
doing stuff which stimulates local
economies and addresses local needs
thanks rob over to joe thank you well
i'm going to agree
uh with the previous two speakers um
leveling up is not something that we can
think as a luxury
um it is an absolute essential um as i
said
um we have the most unbalanced country
in the industrialized world and that
matters
because we it's proven that um
with such an imbalance there's slower
growth um
so i think that the communities such as
stoke on trent central
very much you know whilst we describe
the
i call them the blue wall uh seats as um
deprived left behind communities and
they want to be seen not
not like that not as a liability but as
an untapped talent as an opportunity
we very much want to be part of the the
engine of the new economy
um and to do that there are two elements
there is the
um the element of economic
investment which is is massively
important
but there's also and i think robert just
touched on it
um the element of building social
capital
because the the partnership that we've
seen during
the covid uh pandemic between
volunteering community sector local
government government
in delivering that local resilience that
we've all needed
um has been phenomenal across the
country
and i think it it bodes well for a
different way of working
um a few years back we'll all remember
the big society i think the big society
was a great idea
possibly um not at the right time
because
people saw it as a way of um
of communities helping because of
austerity
um the the community ownership of um
helping to level up is is a vital one
you know i know people people in
stoke-on-trent central very much
don't want things to be done to them
they want to be part of the solution
and that's fundamental so
so i see it as a new collaboration
between between government business
and the local community um to to
to reinforce that sense of um
that resilience can only be generated by
by local community in partnership with
with all those agencies
um as robert said you know that the
investment in in parts of the country
happened
in decades gone by and and i can tell
you quite frankly that
uh we got an 80-seat majority because
people felt left behind
and they didn't see the value of
investments over decades so we've got to
do things differently
i think leveling up and i think actually
the way that the
country has come together during this
pandemic it gives us a real
um a window of opportunity to to
actually
redesign how we deliver um
infrastructure but also
involving community
thanks joe and well honey everyone well
i think daniel joe and rob have outlined
that there is a very strong case for
levelling up
um one of the areas that you know
daniel talked about is is transportation
as um
a catalyst into bringing
wealth into the north into those
deprived areas
um and transport investment goes hand in
hand with the decarbonization
agenda that obviously the government
were pushing forwards long before the
pandemic was apparent and
clearly has to continue hand in hand
covered is undoubtedly going to be
um a short term whatever short term
means
one three five year blip as we all
discussed just now
um but one of the things that we need to
do is
make sure that the investment that um is
kick-starting the economy
is actually correctly um utilized
one of the areas that we need to look at
is actually how
that spending is is turned into
actual infrastructure spend and to
remove the red tape that
we've seen holding up many projects um
and the time to actually get that
stimulus coming
the decarbonization um as daniel
outlined
agenda will drive the advent of hydrogen
it'll bring in
electric trains and bring in far more
um environmentally friendly forms of
transportation
energy production and so forth
but we mustn't just focus upon those
communities in the north that
are deprived undoubtedly they need
economic
stimulus coming in there but you know my
own company for instance
uh thanks to a large order from
transport for london
are investing you know 200 million in
east orchard to build a factory which is
then creating northern jobs
because of spending in london and by the
same token
we mustn't let the south east actually
become deprived in comparison to other
capital cities so that we don't get the
inward investments that we were
fighting so hard for pre-planning um
go elsewhere particularly you know
brexit is is a huge opportunity for us
coming
um to actually have that community where
we welcome in
international companies back into into
the uk and they again can actually help
this leveling up agenda because you know
they don't have to be
london-based but similarly if their
investment can be spread
right the way around the uk it's it's
something that we must
overlook one of the elements that
is absolutely key is the um the whole
agenda of skills
the development of the next generation
and
that again it can be part of our
leveling up agenda and it must be
um you know the concept of apprentices
you know
the levy system and actually getting
people back into training so that we
actually have a far more skilled
workforce
um from all areas but particularly from
those areas where we we believe we need
to invest
is absolutely key and certainly we see
actually a poor take-up in some of our
technical apprentices we have a lot of
overseas
interests in people wanting to come in
um but then we actually have to battle
to being
local people particularly from more
deprived areas
into our training academies today and
this is one of the things that we need
to you know
really push because we can create good
british jobs
for people in all their areas um
if they have a willingness to do that
and
education is obviously absolutely key
so overall i mean leveling up has to go
hand in hand with decarbonization
transportation infrastructure projects
are
the most well what's the best way
are most certainly the um
the best way or one of the best ways
that we can actually start
kick start this but also to bring in
um the skills
agenda and and make sure that
you know we have an inclusive um
agenda going forwards so thanks kate
thanks very much will um we already have
some questions coming in and just a
reminder to our
viewers that you can submit any question
you like through spectator tv
those are directly funneled to me and i
can put them to our panel
and but i'm gonna abuse my position and
ask a few questions first um
daniel we've heard a lot over the years
about
investing in areas that aren't london or
the southeast
a lot of lip service has been paid to
the northern powerhouse
and now it's the leveling up agenda but
i think some would argue
that a lot of this has been talk and
perhaps the people who are supposed to
benefit from these initiatives have
never really
felt that benefit why should we believe
that this time is different
well i think that's right kate and uh
robert married the point that this is
not this is nothing new
right this happened under under blair it
happened you know 15 20 years ago
i think what's different about the
northern powerhouse and and what will
hopefully be different about leveling up
is that collaboration between regions
and between city regions in particular
you know you're starting to see that
collaboration between manchester and
liverpool between
leeds and other parts of yorkshire up to
newcastle you know you're starting to
see those traditional rivalries which
may be based on
decades and generations of enmity
between between towns and cities you're
starting to see them link up in various
different ways
for example advanced manufacturing and
energy and health innovation
areas of expertise in the north that can
create growth and create jobs
but robert mentioned the sort of key
word and and that and that's devolution
and
you could argue that the shining success
of the northern powerhouse
initiative which i probably would agree
with you kate has has not had the
uh resounding impact it it it
would have it should have had partly
because
um when theresa may was pm her her
two advisors used to literally take the
word northern powerhouse out of speeches
um but devolution the
the the the arrival of five metro mayors
in the north of england
uh is arguably its biggest success
and i think you know you're starting to
see during this pandemic the leadership
roles that people like andy burnham and
steve brother and others are starting to
play within their city regions
you know they are leading the charge in
many ways for the businesses in greater
manchester and
other areas and uh looking at what
measures can be taken
to um to actually address the issues of
the pandemic and it was interesting that
on i think it was yesterday or monday it
was andy burnham
10 past eight on today program talking
about the recovery and what must be done
not the mayor of london for example
so i think that those focal points and
those leadership that devolution
provides gives us hope
that this time it could be different i
think we need
100 evolution across the north in
whatever form that might take it won't
necessarily always be metro mayors it
can be different forms
but we need that local control and more
importantly we need that much more
meaningful
powers to be given to our metro mayors
to allow them to take far more control
um in their local areas that applies
right now in the middle of a pandemic
and it applies to the recovery and
do i have hope that's going to happen
well i've just seen this morning in the
ft that the
evolution white paper that's been
promised for what months
is now delayed until next year so do i
hope that's going to happen well
not a huge amount
uh joe how hopeful are you that the
government will
push forward with a devolution agenda
and how far do you think it should go
um i wouldn't be surprised if you know
our entire panel
agreed although let me know if you don't
um that there is a role uh
for central government to play as well
as devolve powers
but where do you think that power
balance should lie joe and
do you think enough is being done to
empower smaller communities to make
these
changes so i have a slightly different
view
from daniel in that uh stoke-on-trent is
um
in the um slightly difficult position
that it is in the west midlands but it's
not in the combined authority in the
west midlands
so and we're not in the northern
powerhouse so we're sort of out on a
limb
um and what we don't want to do by
um devolution is create um
a two-tier hierarchy of of those in
large
areas that that can um access funding
and those that don't
um otherwise we create more left behind
communities just different ones
so i think that i think i think um
moving power down to local communities
is important
however um it is quite a challenge so
so you're absolutely right i do see a
role for for national government very
much
in terms of um how funding is
is um distributed
but i think that local communities
and i mean large communities cities and
towns across the country
have their own local solutions to
leveling up and leveling up in
um the west midlands might look
different from leveling up in cornwall
where they have you know equal social
challenges but
but of a different nature or coastal
communities
so so it's very much about not having a
prescriptive
uh central government line on um in
order to solve leveling up this is
you know this is this funding pot and
and um
you know you all need to apply in the
same way we we very much need to
to have um an opportunity for
local the local design of um what what
leveling up might look like
clearly large infrastructure projects
have to be um
run from from national government um and
and distribution of
i mean things like transport is is an
obvious one that you can't really
devolve um
but the shape of what local transport
should look like is
is something that needs to be designed
locally
rob uh to the point of national
government and the
decisions that are made there you
mentioned in your
opening remarks that we certainly have
the money to invest in
infrastructure and in transport that
borrowing rates are at
a historic low and so it's not too hard
to finance
the debt that will be racked up from
doing so um but
there's a second part to that equation
isn't there it's not just whether or not
you can afford it but whether or not
it's a good project in its own right and
oftentimes
national government is not very good at
looking into its crystal ball and
determining
what the really helpful projects or the
projects with a high rate of return
are going to be do you think that
decision making where the money
is being spent is happening at the right
level of government and are you not
concerned even if we can afford it that
the
wrong decision still might be the wrong
decisions are still being made
especially as it relates to the leveling
up agenda
yeah so over the course of the 20th
century britain went from spending 90
percent of
tax raised locally of raising and
spending 90 attacks locally
to 10 um everything got centralized and
one of the consequences that was to
winnow out
the capacity of local government because
why the hell would you go into it when
you know you didn't have you didn't have
any money and you didn't have any power
so you know i think you know the
national government does not have a
great track record in infrastructure
we've mentioned hs2
you know the cost overruns on that have
been
you know pretty hideous um and that's
not a sort of an unfamiliar tale
and i i think so i you know i think that
you know the treasury's funding formula
is
is one of those classic sort of
government algorithmic spreadsheets with
200 variables which
occasionally spits out the right answer
and occasionally spits out at the wrong
one um
are you i'd like to a little more
private investment i think um
uh trying to you know trying to you know
get some sort of market discipline
would would would definitely be useful
but and i think part of the problem is
we
we haven't we need to be quite
hard-headed about this and allow for
some failure as well as success
like our model of the devolution and
like the
the the industrial strategy which greg
can't produce on the tourism it's
we have a very sort of you know you get
a car you get a car you get a car model
of
um devolution where we give sort of tiny
pots of money to
every part of the country and tell them
to go and compete with china
um i mean neil o'brien who you actually
wrote about was one of the first people
to write about
leveling up although it wasn't called it
for the spectator um
and then um is now one of joe's
colleagues um
you know he did a wonderful exercise
when he was in think tank land of
looking at the mission statements of
every council in the country and every
single council in the country had his
mission statement we are going to make
balsitshire a world-leading center for
life sciences or for the creative arts
or for
you know there were very very few
councils which have gone you know what
we're a bit [ __ ] but we're near a
motorway so we're just going to get
amazon to build some warehouses
and that's our that's our economic usp
you know we don't
we don't really like everyone everyone
thinks they look you know one of like
you know no matter how much we level up
there are always going to be cluster
effects there are always going to be
winners and losers there are always
going to be
you know people who make the right
decisions are people who make the wrong
decisions i think we need to
sort of try and bake that into the
process i would certainly like to see
a lot more control of infrastructure
locally um small infrastructure i think
all national infrastructure i think we
need to be yeah we need to be more
hard-headed about
about um about likely economic gains we
need to learn from
best practice overseas you know we've
not been good buyers
historically we've done a few things
right and a lot of things wrong
well it's always quite telling if a big
government project
especially as it relates to
infrastructure transport isn't getting
any money from the private sector
uh so to what extent can the private
sector help
guide what the uh high rate of return
projects might be and
on that same point how essential is the
private sector
to driving the leveling up agenda how
much money can come through the private
sector how much drive and initiative and
resources can be used there
as opposed to taxpayer money well i mean
as a private sector we are very willing
to finance
infrastructure um in various different
guises whether it's in partnership with
the government or
or taking on 100 um
it's about having the framework within
government
to allow that private funding to come
we have many discussions and many
working groups going on currently
looking at financing for infrastructure
um
you know northern powerhouse rail is uh
possibly
uh one opportunity that that needs to be
examined further
uh but also we're looking at some
london-based schemes where obviously the
the focus has been um infrastructure
projects in the north and and certainly
under the guidance of transport for
london they're looking at how
they could kick start some of the
schemes that may not be on the first
rate of agenda
uh as it moves forwards so i think that
leveling up agenda can most certainly
utilize private finance private um
you know the private sector bringing
skills in there
um and i think if you combine that
financing with more of a
a made in britain type uh approach so
that actually
you are bringing that framework to to
get that stimulus rather than
um utilizing some of the the more
traditional um models whereby you have a
lot of
large european in particular american
companies coming in
with good finance but also with also the
skill sets so that we don't necessarily
see the
the true return for the infrastructure
projects that are
going on and coming back into the uk
daniel we've had an interesting question
from matthew who's watching
he says says that given more and more
people are working from home now and
huge consequence of the pandemic
should the investment that was going to
be put into transportation
be moved towards or redirected towards
technology instead
uh no uh we should have both
there's always this either or kind of
question with the north
which never seems to happen very much in
london you know london can say we need
crossrail and we need
um the high speed one railing can we
need everything else now we need
crosstalk too
in the north it's kind of should we have
a or should we have b you know this has
very much been the
debate around hs2 and northern
powerhouse rail and i think it's exactly
the same
situation with um with getting fiber to
the premises and ultra fast broadband
you know so we have
uh areas of the north that suffer
terribly with
with lack of connectivity you know we
should have a situation where you can
run a business just as well from the
center of manchester or
san francisco or the middle of
northumberland but unfortunately that's
that's not the case um so we should have
both you know there are
uh to take up on the point you you were
asking will about about the private
sector
i'd go a little bit further than will
and say that um
private sector is champing at the bit to
get involved in supporting
um some of these leveling up
infrastructure projects but they don't
have there isn't the clarity and there
isn't the opportunity there yet
for them to know how to do so so
you know we have uh communications
providers people like talk talk and
others and city fibre who are
you know ready to go with that kind of
laying um fiber to the premises and some
of the
left behind areas if you like but it's
not that they haven't
had the green light to go ahead with it
so and
we need both the working from home issue
is is often put up by the kind of hs2 no
says there's a reason not to invest in
massive infrastructure but we've all
talked about
cobit as i said hopefully being a blip
and while the
the world of work will almost almost
undoubtedly change people will still
need to travel around the country and
freight will need to travel around the
country
and capacity on local networks um
is still hugely constrained and we need
to address all of those points and
high-speed rail is a very
good way of doing that if i can just
very very quickly um
kate pick up a point that that joe made
about about trump transport investment
and
control of that of course it's
absolutely right that central government
should be
in charge of national infrastructure
projects but allowing
locally elected leaders to have control
over local
transport structures is really important
and actually the sooner we get london
style ticketing
um price ticketing on on on networks
uh in the north the better um in greater
manchester you can go from bolton to
stockport and pay 15 pounds a day on
three different
types of transport that are not
integrated well in london you do that
for one pound fifty so
local transport solutions are equally
important really are sorting out the
national
transport infrastructure joe i suppose
this
matthew's question really gets to the
heart of this topic today about what the
uk
can realistically afford despite having
found that magic money tree in the
backyard of the bank of england we know
that
the huge amount of money that's um being
used to directly finance the treasury
right now is to get us through
the cova crisis the bank has been very
clear it has no plans to
pay for the government's day-to-day
spending and with virtually
every sector now demanding more
resources health
education welfare and at some point a
conservative government is going to have
to make
some trade-offs and and choose its
priorities and if you do have
significantly more people working from
home and a big dip
in those using public transport is that
not something to consider when we're
talking about the leveling up agenda
it's certainly difficult to um to
foresee
you know how long the new normal is
going to go on whether we will ever go
back to
the model where people commute um
so i i think it's very difficult to
design
the the transport system for the future
i think what we need to do
however is is make sure that
when we're talking about the government
decisions on investment
to make sure that going forward
investment is linked to um
social and environmental benefits um i
think that you know the the
what the pandemic has done has made
people refocus on
what's important to them and and i can
say honestly that that
um in four years time
if if somebody asks the people of stoke
on transcentral what leveling up looks
like to them
it's going to be something very
immediate and very small we've discussed
you know
um a large rail project isn't going to
be finished in four years so
so that element of um
something meaningful that this impacted
them so we talked
we'll talk briefly about the skills
agenda so i'm very keen
to make sure that the the opportunities
for
the new types of jobs that are emerging
um can be taken up by by young people in
stoke-on-trent
so i think that very much investment has
to be around
um a sense of beginning the journey of
leveling up because leveling up is a
long-term thing
and and you know we we all know
realistically
that um that we have to start somewhere
and we have to show
show that that clear intention which is
um
that people realize that that
we know we're on a journey with them i
know that sounds a bit corny but but
it is important because we cannot
deliver
massive infrastructure projects um in
the short term
and we need to we need to plan for that
that longer term future
and give people hope that the things
will change
can i just say briefly i mean in stoke
one of the key issues that we have is
you know post-industrial brownfield
sites um
are scattered throughout the
constituency and land values are so low
that um the the remediation costs
are just not justifiable for it for a
commercial investor
uh without help so that is a very
specific thing where
you know i'm i'm campaigning that we
should we should get help because
um that that would unlock huge amounts
of of
of land both for um residential and for
um for commercial purposes and that
would make a real
a real visible you know fairly
short-term difference
well joe picks up on your point there
about
skill sets and let's focus in on this
for a minute because a lot of our
conversation so far has been how level
leveling up relates to money spent on
infrastructure projects and
rail but uh the kova 19 crisis
has in many ways changed what it means
to level up hasn't it as so many young
people in particular have lost out on
opportunities
in the best case scenario they've been
working from home and not getting
contact time
with their bosses or new contacts in the
industry and of course in the worst case
scenario
they're in a group most likely to have
been furloughed or lost their jobs
during this pandemic i
i know that siemens has its own
apprenticeship scheme
what more do you think could be done in
the public and private sector to help
level up from a skills
perspective and also particularly
thinking about young people who have
fallen off
the jobs ladder or struggling to make
their way up
i think the first thing you pick up on
the fact that many apprentices and many
trainees have actually been furloughed
um
because of the requirement of
interaction
what we're seeing um is you know we're
back with the
in the autumn we have a new intake of
trainees coming into the industry
traditionally they come in september and
october and
you know subject to the virus you know
not getting worse
and that's not having a full lockdown
one of the things that we're trying to
work out
in my business but also in industry
generally is actually how you get that
face-to-face time and how we can
actually
kick-start today um the training is
taking place
and that requires bringing people into a
socially distanced
academy in order to you know to actually
give them those practical skills and we
don't want
to slow down um the pull through of
our trainees and apprentices because
that will actually slow down our ability
to actually
perform in three to five years time
because it's a continual
um process of bringing people in and the
demographics particularly within the
infrastructure side of things show that
we have a large amount of people sort of
over 45 who
be retiring and sort of coming out of
the industry so i think that
skills assist in in leveling up i mean
trainees apprentices or graduates or
wherever
they're open to anybody so it's about
actually getting
the word out into areas like joe's
constituency that you know
there are training programs that are
available um and perhaps even actually
going with a specific agenda to try and
um
bring in as as london did actually in
number with a lot of the
the london-based contracts for
infrastructure they said you had to
bring in a certain number of apprentices
from certain boroughs
uh and we could adopt something you know
on a national basis in order to
to start bringing the skill sets into
the people in those deprived areas
but overall we've got to be able to kick
start the training and get the people
into the academies again
rob what do you think about the impact
of the pandemic on
leveling up a question from allison here
says do you think the
treasury and number 10 decisions in
light of covid whether that be
and from the lockdown that we had to the
measures they put in place to try to
come back from it
are going to drive more leveling up in
the medium to long term or
actually they're going to risk further
disparity there's a
there's some two answers to that um the
first is that recessions
in general are unfair they tend to hit
the young
and the poor and the badly trained and
the insecure uh hardest and they tend to
you know hit the those with assets and
good jobs and you know
resilience uh better and you know that's
kind of that's what we saw going out
over the lockdown
it's probably what we're going to see
playing out as as companies make hiring
investment decisions in
in the coming months you know uh you
know and the idea with you and then
generally speaking you know you you then
have a period of a few years where
you things are tougher for those at the
bottom end and but
but you know eventually when the economy
returns to growth think
things catch up so there's that to to
focus on but then also
obviously um you know the carotid virus
is driving shifts into behavior and we
don't what we don't know yet is
is how sort of uh how permanent those
shifts are um
you know a lot of people are sort of
saying well you know if if london
empties out for example isn't it going
to be sort of
good for for leveling up but you know uh
you know saying for some leagues or
manchester or wherever else but you know
i think there's a
like you know i think activity in london
you know people who used to work in
central london are probably going to go
and
stay in outer london or like the kind of
the leafy affluent suburbs then
you i don't see how the impact of
coronavirus in london
then leads to suddenly lots of uh you
know
uh lots of people who who are going to
press in victoria three are suddenly
going to go to
sort of um turn up in skunk thought what
he said i think there's a you know
or all kind of different they're
deprived equivalents in the uk so
i think there's you know i think there's
going to be a distributional effect
but i don't think it's going i don't
think it's going to sort of
you know if you were living in a if
you're living in working in a nice area
you still want to be living and working
in a nice area
um you know and you know i i
come from oxfordshire i was home at the
other the other weekend
um and apparently you know the estate
agents there are the busiest they have
ever been
because everyone wants to run away to a
nice house with a garden
um yeah so i think that i think there's
that there's that element there
um uh i mean i think that you know the
pandemic
it's obviously having an impact can i
have any public finances on what we can
afford
so far the government you know in the
spirit of its prime minister seems to be
wanting to have its cake and eat it
that's um you know i mean i i am biased
on this because
i took leave for help on the manifesto
but the you know the
the principles of the manifesto still
apply like you know if you thought that
leveling up was the was the solution
before this crisis
those very distributional impacts i was
talking about mean that it is even more
the solution
after the crisis you know if things were
unfair before and they are even more
unfair now
then you need to then you need to act so
you know i don't think people are going
to sort of forget about this agenda
because of the chronovirus but obviously
it makes it harder for an awful lot of
people and especially
as we're seeing you know young people
who have been you know
this is a very very weird disease and it
hits the oldest
hardest as a disease but as an economic
disease it hits the youngest absolutely
uh
you know it just really has a really
gross effect
joe uh basically the day after
the 2019 general election their
speculation began
about what was going through the minds
of former red wall voters when they
decided to
give their vote to the conservative
party and and many still think
that the vote is not forever but lent
they are willing to try something new
try something different and see how it
goes
how important is the leveling up agenda
to maintaining
trust with these new voters that the
conservative party has brought on board
well it's clearly essential because um
the reason they they
we all know you know there were three
key reasons that they voted conservative
brexit being one um jeremy corbyn's
lack of popularity in in areas like mine
the second and then a general confidence
in um
boris johnson as as prime minister to be
able to deliver
uh on the you know the manifesto that we
put out and
on the economy so um you know clearly
the next election the first two
don't play a role and therefore the
third is is very important
um and that's why i said that that
whilst it's really important that we
invest
heavily in in areas like stoke on trend
we also need
to do things in in the shorter term that
show people
um that we're on um
on a mission to deliver what we said and
um there is a strange sort of stoicism
in stone there's a fantastic sense of
place
people people love love the city and um
a lot of them have never left it and
never will leave it so that there's a
there's a great sense of place but
there's also a sense of
it's always been like this and nothing's
going to change anytime soon
so um to to show that something is
changing
and and and will change is going to be
not just a
you know leap of faith on their part
that we have to have something
something visible um so it will it will
be a challenge
and um you know i'm determined that um
that's why they voted for um
you know people like me across across
the uh say we call them the the
blue wall seats um because
you know genuinely they were sick of
being promised change and then
seeing nothing nothing visible happen
um for decades so yeah
it's really important daniel on this
point of
maintaining trust and delivering on
promises
what does success look like when will we
know that we've leveled up
i think that's a really interesting
question and
doesn't have a simple answer but
ultimately
leveling up will only really be achieved
when you have a north that is
as prosperous as itself when you have a
child
growing up in um in parts of merseyside
or
or the northeast who has the same life
chances as someone growing up in
kensington
um it will only really happen when the
northern
city regions and other areas pull their
weight in productivity terms and these
are all as i said at the beginning
these are all very long term uh
ambitions that doesn't mean there are
not things that can be done in the short
term i've talked about evolution we've
talked about infrastructure investment
but
you know we have far more areas of
of disadvantage in educational terms in
any part of the country
and as i said the pandemic has only
really exacerbated those you know you've
got
children who've been off school for
months without any
uh form of online learning or any form
of support necessary and
the the lack of um
speed and the lack of progress from
central government in
providing support for these these
families and these children not just in
the north but all around the country
has been has been hugely disappointing
and actually it's been the private
sector who stepped forward and provided
laptops
um for a lot of these families um to be
able to to do some kind of home learning
and you know all the estimates are that
that has just widened the educational
divide between haves and have-nots and
unfortunately we have more of those in
the north so
it comes you know rob mentioned at the
beginning that that skills should play a
big part of the level of agenda i'd go
back even further than that and say the
education system
plays a huge part in it so until we fix
the education system go right back to
the
kind of grass roots almost and right
back to the beginning of the problem
um you know you won't see leveling up in
any true form um
and short-term measures to try and um
maintain that electoral advantage for
example just won't cut it it has to be
that that long term
that that long term generational reform
and well a lot of people now want to
couple
all of these initiatives from government
into one you look at the covert recovery
the leveling up agenda the green
revolution
they think this is an opportunity to
tackle all these things head on rather
than to try to break them down
to what extent do you think the green
revolution going green
moving away from the fossil fuel
industry and uh
leveling up can can go hand in hand or
are these just
too big too big of topics at
too big of goals to really try to
combine into one
well i think that yeah there is an
agenda already a green agenda which
uh started long before covert and we
already have
the targets outlining the paris
agreements and those time scales haven't
changed
that pipeline of work you know if i take
where i work in transportation
the agenda is still there what we
actually need is just
the opportunity to start or to continue
on the journey that we had started
you know over the previous years
technology's being developed and you
know there's a digital revolution going
on that's enabling
um far more green practices uh across
infrastructure but across you know the
way that we
um do our but maintain our lives we have
um
considerable you know considerably deep
pockets for this agenda
we want to invest our money and we just
want to get out there
and and start moving uh and things are
happening even in this uncovered
environment you know
it's it's um announced i think today
that with birmingham university the
the first hydrogen train is going to be
going over the the uk
um rail network in forms of trials so
even with this cove
environment we are pushing forwards on
that green agenda
and i think you know something like high
speed 2 is often
sort of just viewed as a new passenger
railway line what people forget is the
green aspects of high speed 2 of taking
you know
thousands of tons of freight off the
motorway network on a daily basis and
actually reducing the carbon footprint
because it opened up
train paths on the existing west coast
main line so
it's just having the environment cutting
out you know
uh the blocks that are there so that we
can actually start delivering these
and i think if government can do
anything if they can accelerate some of
the
the green agenda um it will actually
help the leveling up because a lot of
this green agenda is centered around
um the northern um areas
and in scotland as well so
we've got the framework we just need to
be able to do it
but rob of course the energy white paper
has been delayed
plans for further devolution have been
delayed
understandably so this year we know why
they've been delayed and i think you can
cut the government
slack for that but is this going to
prove problematic
especially in terms of an election
timeline but also putting
you know the politics of it aside just
for the quality of
people's lives uh you know every year
that goes by where action isn't taken is
a year lost uh so how much more time
realistically
can we wait to really get some of these
plans underway
well i think um you know it it's
entirely understandable why these
studies have happened you know
as i did a lot you know the sort of
shorthand
you know you know the the good civil
servants were who were all pulled onto
this crinovirus uh
planning the you know and then the the
slightly less good ones were pulled onto
no deal brexit planning and then you
left a couple of people
sort of minding the shop on everything
else um
that said you know next year the uk is
is um hosting
the the conference on um climate change
you know these these
were these things have been delayed they
haven't been pushed back they were all
even
they're mostly in a state of in in a
sort of pretty good
state as far as i'm aware um you know
they're quite clear on what they want to
do
i don't think this is you know i don't
think a few months delay is going to
sort of massively uh alter the
also the terrain all the planets and you
know as joe was saying you know
you know in big infrastructure projects
just they're sort of longer than the
electrical timeline
timeline anyway um you know there is
going to be a comprehensive
spending review in the next few weeks
almost where
uh you know i think a lot of the
infrastructure spending is going to be
set out
um that's uh you know they pulled the
budget but you know
yeah they need to tell us where they're
going to spend the money and i think
they probably are
uh i think we've got time for another
question to go around the panel
and this question from dominic i'd like
to put to
all of you he's asking what is the best
way to encourage your growth and
productivity
which lags greatly behind london in the
southeast in many regions and
that's such an important point because
it's not just about creating the
structures or the infrastructure
to level up but then also boosting
productivity boosting wages and the rest
um so daniel i'll start with you just
give me one or two ideas as to how we
can really use productivity
in other parts of the country
i think the whole northern powerhouse
principle was about the the aim of it
was to
increase productivity and better linking
the northern regions is the key to that
productive productivity increase that
doesn't just mean a fast train line
although
we believe that is actually very
important anyone who's tried to get a
train
from manchester to leeds or or god
forbid from another port of hull
um will will fully understand uh the
importance of improving that side of it
but it's that collaboration
and that linking up of assets as well
which is really important you know if
you link up advanced manufacturing
strengths for example
um in the sheffield city region up with
cumbria up with the northeast up to
particular manchester and merseyside
or do the same with energy you know you
start to get a critical mass of
expertise
and you start to get exportable
industries that can raise the
productivity of both of the north and
the whole country
but also can create industries that can
be that can be
exported to other parts of the country i
think we have a great opportunity in
this world talks about hydrogen and that
is one
significant opportunity not just for
transport but also for domestic heating
as well i think small modular reactors
in the nuclear sector is another
a live opportunity um and i think there
are lots of these opportunities that the
north needs
to work together on to put compelling
cases to central government for initial
investment into projects that then can
lead to productivity increases again i
should say
productivity increases are not things
that happen overnight and the uk
has had traditional um low productivity
in the north has been a key part of that
but i think it would be a step in the
right direction to create the networks
and the collaboration needed
to allow that to happen well indeed and
will
the productivity puzzle and how to boost
it has been a conundrum for some time
now long before
the covet crisis so um you know it's
it's a big question but a few ideas from
you as to how we might be able to
boost growth and productivity outside of
london
well i totally agree with everything
daniel says and the ability to
move and to
bring the northern cities together
undoubtedly will assist
productivity but i think it also goes
back to actually the skill of the
workforce as well and i think the
education and um
making sure that we have that the right
uh skill sets
in order to fulfill you know the
industry within the north is absolutely
key as well
so going back to what we're talking
about apprentices and um the whole
whole concept of actually upskilling uh
the younger generation
in in the north and perhaps
tailoring that to you know those
industries that
can be linked up by greater um
connectivity
and you know the digital um
revolution that we we lived through over
the last 10 years
push forwards and a lot of transferable
skills
that could be brought together across
all in industry
that again could help uh to level up
what we see in the south
um uh and the north
thanks will joe what are your ideas for
boosting productivity
yeah so i i think one of the i can't
remember who earlier said
every local area aspires to be
world-class in everything i think you
need to
focus on what you're good at uh in
stoke-on-trent obviously it's the home
of ceramics
i've been pushing um with
a number of local partners for an
advanced ceramics campus which will
bring together our world-class r d
um manufacturers uh education
so you know new jobs in the pipeline as
well
um and i think that we have to focus on
on what we
what we're particularly good at i mean
interestingly in stoke on trend
and productivity has increased by 6.8
percent since 2002 so
um our problem is that that as
projectives increase wages haven't
um but there are certainly um
opportunities and
um uh interestingly i was talking to
michelin last week they have uh their
european uh retread business in
stoke-on-trent and they were saying that
that actually it's a very agile
workforce and they've been able to do in
stoke-on-trent what they couldn't do in
germany or france or
um other european countries which was to
to to work a shift pattern
um which was extremely flexible um in
line with
the union support so i think that you
know my shameless plug for stoke on
trent is a great place to invest
it's a great place um to do business and
and you know
please come here because we've got a you
know a really great night our workforce
um but productivity is all about pulling
all those elements together
and and and the specialism that you can
really deliver on i think
and rob be great to hear your ideas as
well and i would probably just throw
one challenge to you it it strikes me
that
productivity may well be gained as we
recover from the kovac crisis
slowly but hopefully surely but that
could be gained through
technology advancements automation and
it may actually result
in fewer jobs at least in the short term
so
and what are your ideas for boosting
productivity and how do we handle the
risk that is poised to some of those
lower skilled jobs as companies move
more
online they go digital and that possibly
means fewer jobs in the short term
you know i mean one of the trade-offs
we've made as a country and you saw it
very clearly after 2008 is that we
you know we have very very low
unemployment but the consequence of that
is we employ quite a lot of
low-skilled people um and that's
probably a trade-off that was worth
making
um especially and it might be worth
making again now
but you you do need to drive
productivity up um
so skills is a big part of it um
training we do we do very very little
training in
in the workforce compared with um other
countries uh business investment
um we've called for um reform of the
capital expensing uh rules because
you know it it it currently the tax
system is that effectively punishes you
for enlarging your premises or upgrading
your
equipment and partly as a result of that
you know companies like
like you know it's like for siemens
in the uk generally like companies just
buy fewer robots they buy
fewer productivity enhancing tools than
they would in the equivalent companies
in
in germany or france or elsewhere um
another thing which
it always comes back to me is the
housing system so one of the big reasons
we have a productivity problem is is we
don't
match the best and most talented and
most ambitious workers
with the best uh and most uh productive
jobs
because those workers if they aren't
like lucky enough to have rich parents
cannot afford to live in the places
where the good jobs are so
you know we do so people you know people
just tend to work in jobs which are not
optimizing their earning
capacity or their output because they
just can't afford to move anywhere else
well fascinating insights from our panel
i'm sorry that we can't thank you in the
usual way but i'm sure that our
audiences in their offices and at home
will join me in lightly applauding for
will daniel joe and rob thank you so
much to the panel and thank you again
to siemens for sponsoring it i think we
got a lot of
great ideas out of it today and if
anybody joined us
late or only for a few minutes you'll be
able to catch up with this whole panel
on spectator tv as well as all the other
panels that we hosted
these past few days go over to
tv.spectator.com.uk
will daniel joe and rob thanks again
have a great day